i've been a fan of yours for a very long
time it is great to talk with you oh
thank you i appreciate it
uh so i have actually seen all of the
morning show season two and it is what
we call very good um i just want to
start with that i think fans are going
to love it um uh but before we get into
the morning show season two and your
great work on it i'm curious if we could
just go jump backwards for a quick
second uh i read
that when
you back a long time ago you did some
homicide and you were offered a an
extended role on homicide but you
elected to go with er
instead of doing homicide and i'm just
curious how scared were you when you
made that decision that you made the
wrong decision
oh that's a great question thanks for
asking it um i actually write about that
in the memoir i just uh that just came
out that i wrote because
uh it was one of it was like playing
russian roulette you know you didn't i
didn't know if i was making the biggest
mistake of my life
but um
it was one of those
things where i got lucky because i
called tom fontana who had offered me
the role on homicide
and i said i i don't don't know how i
can turn this down when i'm unemployed
but i might george clooney told me i
might live on er what what should i do
and he said go with the r there'll
always be a role for you here
so
he made that decision much easier for me
um and i and we've remained good friends
ever since
uh yes that that's one of those
life-changing moments i'm very happy i'm
very happy you worked out yeah me too
um so uh i am curious with the morning
show how much did they tell you about uh
uh your character's arc when you signed
on and how much is it sort of like oh
the season one's really good uh i'd i'd
be you know lucky to join the show
i definitely felt um the second that the
call came in that they wanted me on the
show i thought oh i need to know who
this character is but pretty much
without even seeing who the character
was i wanted to join the show because i
was a fan of the show
um i i was the act the caliber of acting
and the writing um
just the whole production value i just
thought that i want to be a part of
it also was really enticing for me to
join a show that was already a
well-oiled machine where i wouldn't have
to carry it i could just play
which is a rare moment for me and
especially when we were sitting in the
middle of a pandemic which was really
frightening
um just the idea of working again felt
so good
so uh then carrie aaron
uh sent me an outline of who laura
peterson
is
it wasn't so much as the arc of her
story where it was going what i loved
was she gave me a 20-year history
up until when we meet her which i
thought was really extraordinary and for
an actor who gets to build a character
from scratch
it gave me so much to work with
so knowing her history and knowing who
she was and what she went through when
you meet her
i really didn't need to know much about
where she was going
um they gave me a few things a few
little tidbits um and i actually am one
of the only people i think
i haven't seen it yet i haven't seen any
of it so i don't know what stayed in or
what was edited out um but hopefully
i'll i'll be watching it soon but one of
the things i loved about
who laura
is to the other characters on the show
is i felt like she was sort of this calm
presence
in the midst of this crazy
storm
of chaos
where every character is going through
this incredible identity crisis
but she's been there done that she knows
who she is
so it was sort of i felt like i was
coming in more as a pillar of strength
for
um the crazy that was going on
and it was a really uh interesting
sort of way to come into a character
just knowing their backstory but not
quite knowing where she was going with
it i knew a few little things but not
not everything
i totally agree with what you're saying
she is the only person who really has
her [ __ ] together you know like
completely knows who she is it's
comfortable in her skin
and and uh and you play it so well um i
i am so you get to work with mimi again
after all these you know it's been a
while can you sort of talk about what it
was like working with her again after er
so many years ago
well so here's the sad the sad thing
is that i never i never got her as my
director i did six episodes start i did
uh
three four five six eight and nine and
she directed
uh seven and ten and one
so i never worked with her
however she was there the first day i
got there and she can you know we we all
work together on what the character
should look like and um how the
characters you know should be introduced
into the show
and i have to say
um you know the first day when you're
starting on a show that's already
established it can be a little
nerve-racking and i got home that night
and she said i just want you to know
we're watching dailies and spot on so
just knowing that she had my back and
was there
as moral support was enough for me and
it was like coming home because
aside from mimi leader um
leslie linkaglatter who directed episode
three was also a director i'd worked
with on er and the good wife
and she and i have been producing
something together for years that hasn't
gotten off the ground yet it will um so
so i felt a familiarity with with
with them as well as
jen
who we started out together on thursday
night lineup you know
musty tv we were on the same lot
we were uh right next door to each other
and we came out of the gate the exact
same time and we knew each other and
reese i had known on and off we had
shared the same uh agent for a while i
knew her a little bit from from um
events we had been at
and i it just felt like sort of coming
home into this very embracing
uh
like welcome when i got here when i say
here la because i live in new york and
i'm in l.a now
i understand you have some great scenes
with reese um
and i don't want to get into
too many specifics but i'm just curious
if you could talk a little bit about
working with her and you know the
importance of portraying
what is in the show honestly
so
you know
there's an ease
to reese uh
above and beyond every anything reese is
so professional
um
and i really understand and appreciate
what it means to be
at the top of a call sheet and to also
be producing that show that you're
starring in right so i had seven years
experience of that
and she
right away
um
when i got to when i got to la said i'm
so excited you're doing this is there
anything you want to talk about right
away opened up the gates for me to be
able to
get in there and not worry about
anything
and the truth is she's just a lot of fun
to work with on top of being talented so
um it was light and easy and felt very
natural there was nothing we did where
either of us felt uncomfortable ever
um
i it never even dawned on me that i
might feel uncomfortable when i was in
her presence so it was really just about
the work and we had a ball together it
was um
it felt very seamless like i just i went
in in the and it just i blended in with
everyone and i never felt like i was an
outsider and that was really
um i always feel you do your best work
when you feel safe
um in a working environment which is why
the crew is always so important to me
i want i want everyone to be happy on a
set and i could see that reese
treated her crew and and her cast the
same way i did and that that gave me a
tremendous amount of solace so i i
really felt um embraced and lucky
thank you so much for your time
seriously great work this season i think
you'll like it when you see it thank you
have a good day thank you